uh why don't we go next over to
let's go to Geron from Atlanta Geron
you're on the air
hey David thank you so much for having
me on
my pleasure
I wanted to ask about what you thought
of the job that Janet Yellen has been
doing especially with this new uh deal
the world uh corporate Global Tax
minimum I want to know what you thought
about that yeah I mean my general take
on Yelling so far is she's she's been
predictable we had a sense you know when
she was selected by Joe Biden there were
some on the left who said this is
another neoliberal Centrist and you know
I took the time of digging into papers
she's written and and work that she's
done and she's definitely you know she
she she's definitely not a socialist
right which is no surprise neither is
Joe Biden but her perspectives are
um sort of as left as one might imagine
a Mainline Democratic president would
have uh when it comes to her outlook on
inflation and interest rates it's been
sort of unremarkable but I'm I'm
basically with her about it's really too
soon to make any uh serious decisions or
or have any serious sense of the
direction that inflation is going as far
as the global wealth tax I saw the
proposal some period of time did
something new happen in the last week
that I missed with it
uh I haven't seen anything about that I
just saw the G7 deal
I think it's an interesting idea and and
for people who don't know the the point
of of some of this is if you can get
countries to come together and say all
of us are going to agree that
individuals cannot avoid taxes in one
member country by shifting income to
another member country and we want a
base minimum level of Global Tax that is
going to be paid I think it's an
interesting idea I see it very difficult
to enforce and it's one of those things
where I I would really want to know the
details of how they're proposing it be
done
um and then where would disputes be
adjudicated related to it like there's
questions which maybe have been answered
and I haven't looked into it enough yet
I think it's super interesting I don't
know how you really get it done
yeah um I think it's great that she's
starting to hold uh and as well as the
other economic leaders of the Free World
starting to hold multinational
corporations accountable yeah absolutely
absolutely with that being the end goal
is something I'm completely behind the
implementation and how you get it done
is where I where I'd want to know more
and also just one quick thing uh for the
future Outlook of Yellen um do you think
she'll be able to do a good job of
managing inflation as we get out of this
pandemic phase
you know I do think so
um I mean I I think she seems to
understand that the numbers from March
and April really don't tell us what we
need to know to come up with a
comprehensive and more reliable Outlook
um I have every confidence that she has
the knowledge and experience to
successfully manage inflation I have no
real concern right now
that's really great Insight uh I'm I'm
just a high schooler I took an economics
class no way a political class is this
stuff really interests me so I really
appreciate uh you taking the time
brilliant all right thank you for the
culture Ron
thank you so much all right wow Jaron in
high school would not have guessed that
uh from the uh from the questions that
were coming in